Apple unveils its first original series to premiere on Apple Music.
The trailer for the show was released February 13th at the Code Media conference.
It's called "Planet of the Apps",...
...a reality show that's been described as a cross between "Shark Tank" and "The Voice."
Contestants are app developers who have 60 seconds...
...to pitch their idea to a panel of four celebrity judges...
...while standing on a descending escalator.
The four judges include actresses Jessica Alba and Gwyneth Paltrow,...
...musician Will.I.Am and entrepreneur Gary Vaynerchuk.
If one of them likes the idea enough, the contestant can partner with the judge,...
...who will act as an adviser.
The show culminates in contestants getting to make their pitch...
...to a venture capitalist group for funding.
The trailer's elicited mixed reactions,...
...with much negative feedback coming from the world of developers...
...and some of Apple's own employees.
For NewsBeat Social, I'm Matt Paul.